اذا ايام تفصل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عن التخلف عن سداد ديونها حال عدم الاتفاق
على رفع سقف الدين نتحدث هنا عن الاول من
مايو او يونيو تحديدا لكن ما هي
السيناريوهات المطروحه حتى ذلك اليوم بحسب
خبراء الاقتصاد السيناريو الاول هو التوصل
الى اتفاق في اللحظه الاخيره وهنا حاله
عدم اليقين قد تدفع المستهلكين وايضا
المستثمرين والشركات للتردد في انفاق
الاموال ما يزيد من فرص حدوث ركود وتراجع
باسعار الاسهم
السيناريو الثاني هو التوصل الى اتفاق بعد
الموعد النهائي وفي حال تجاوز المفاوضات
الاول من يونيو قد تكون رده الفعل اكثر
حده مثل تراجع الانفاق بشكل كبير وايقاف
الشركات لخطط التوظيف وايضا الاستثمار
ويقدر اقتصاديون ان ينكمش الناتج المحلي
باثنين في المئه الربع الثالث وخساره 250
الف وظيفه في النصف الثاني من هذا العام
اما السيناريو الثالث فهو عدم التوصل
الاتفاق وفي هذا السيناريو
يتجاوز الاثر نطاق وحدود الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وستحدث فوضى في النظام العالمي
المالي مع حدوث ركود عالمي اذا اكثر مما
حدث في عام 2008 التباين ما زال سيد
الموقف بين الطرفين الاداره الامريكيه
وايضا الكونجرس البيت الابيض يرفضون
اللجوء الى التعديل الرابع عشر من الدستور
لرفع سقف الدين بالقوه ويتهم جمهوري
الكونجرس باخذ الاقتصاد
رهينه اجوندا سياسيه خاصه قبل الانتخابات
الرئاسيه العام المقبل على الضفه الاخرى
يطالب رئيس مجلس النواب كيفن ماكورتي
بموافقه الاداره على اجراء خفض كبير في
نفقات الميزانيه وابقائه عند مستويات عام
معتبرا ان الامر خط احمر لا يمكن التنازل
عنه الا ان الاداره الامريكيه وما تواصل
المفاوضات قالت ان بعض التقدم حدث الا انه
على الطرفين ان يفهم انهما لن يحصل على كل
ما يرغبان به وفق المتحدثه باسم البيت
الابيض لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات